All right. Itai Pinki!
Thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me.
You know, just five minutes ago,
you sent me, on WhatsApp,
pictures of us from 11 years ago
in my bar mitzvah.
I still remember that day,
I'll never forget it,
the day that you came to my house
so that we can discuss
the bar mitzvah plan.
And half an hour through,
you had my watch on your wrist.
And I'll never forget that moment
that my mind is
just out of this world.
I think you traumatized me really.
I think that's what happened.
If you're being traumatized,
then you invite people
to your you know podcast, that's weird.
[laughs]
Definitely, definitely.
No, but seriously,
I think magic is just
so incredibly powerful;
that sensation that it gives people
and the impact
that it leaves on people.
Talk to me a little bit
about what you do.
You're one of the most
incredible magicians in Israel.
Talk to me about that.
Thank you, first of all.
I think you said it by yourself.
I think magic is the only art form
that creates a unique sensation.
I think like, For instance,
when you see a juggler
juggling 10 knives
or an acrobat doing crazy stuff
with, I don't know what,
you say,
"Oh, my god, that's amazing,"
you applaud;
you respect them
for their practice
and for their art.
When you see a magic,
a good magic trick
or a magic show,
you ask how.
This is the only art form
that creates this kind
of question, saying,
"How does he do it?"
You know it makes this in your brain.
Yeah.
This is why magic is happening
and still happening for years.
Because human beings love
to be you know intrigued and say, "How?"
Yes.
Because you know,
we're intelligent people.
We know how things work.
When you become an adult,
you understand life.
Then comes someone,
and like this.
[snaps fingers]
makes your watch disappear,
like you say, "Oh, my god,
I'm intelligent.
How did you do it
without me noticing?"
- So I think --
-Right.
[crosstalk]
Walk me a little bit
back in your life
because I have to know
how do you even get started
as a magician.
How do you discover
this innate passion of yours
to amaze and intrigue people?
I don't know who said it.
One of the greatest
painters in the world.
He said, "A painter is a kid that
just continued with his doodling."
Every kid does this
when he's a kid.
And then, you become
a painter, a famous painter,
an artist when
you become an adult.
- Not all of us.
- Right.
A lot of people
can play the piano.
Not everyone becomes Beethoven.
So mgic is the same.
I think most of the kids,
I think mainly boys,
get like magic kits,
or magical book
or something like this,
and they play with it
like for 10 minutes or a week,
and then they stop.
I know you're more than that
because you love magic,
but most of the kids
are like doing it for a week
or a few days.
And then, they continue playing
basketball or whatever it is,
-their other hobbies.
-Right.
I think a magician is just a kid
that continued.
He just loved it
and did it more and more
from this because --
Like every time we did
the magic trick for someone --
I began magic when I was 15-ish
and left it,
and left it and continued with my sports.
And at the age of like 19,
give or take,
I came back to this
like my passion.
My kids --
as a kid,
my passion when I was a kid.
And every person
I showed him a magic trick told me,
"Okay, can I have your
business card?"
And I was like,
"What business card?
This is a hobby, man.
I'm just doing this
to hit on girls."
And people told me,
"But this is like you can
make a living out of this,"
like, "I need your business card.
I have an event," or whatever.
And when you hear it,
once you say,
"Okay, that's a great compliment."
When you hear it
like 15 times a day,
you say, "I think I should
make a living out of this."
So that was 19 years old
when you decided to go to go
from a hobby to actually becoming
a full-time magician?
As a profession?
Yeah, I think when I'm like 20,
I already like you know got booked
for serious events.
-Incredible!
Not huge conferences,
but it was like I got paid
already for my gigs.
Right. So now, Itai,
you're a little bit different
in the field in the sense
that you're not just going
and doing street magic
in bar mitzvahs
and weddings, and so on,
but you do huge conferences
and you're doing a show,
and you call it stand-up magic.
-Yeah.
-I'd love for you to tell me
a little bit about this
combination of stand-up
and magic and how do these
two intertwine with each other.
Yeah, so first of all,
the combination is,
as you said, stand-up magic,
you can understand by the name.
It combines stand-up
comedy and magic.
The combination, I think,
is natural, because most of the
magicians use comedy
or try to be funny, at least.
I don't know
whether they're all funny
but they try.
They use gags and comedy bits.
And stand-up comedy
is being funny.
The art form is very similar.
The crowd,
the target audience is the same.
Stand-up comedy and magic,
it's entertainment.
Sure.
It's not like combining
ballet dancing
with stand-up comedy
or you know opera with magic.
But it's still forces you
to be creative enough
to create a show that has
both the elements of jokes
--  and entertainment
--  Yeah.
on the set of comic,
but also the magician's wow factor.
Yeah, actually, it's much more
than just comedy and jokes.
It's literally I needed to begin
a new art from the beginning
to being a stand-up comedian.
For the crowd, it's okay,
it's like the same,
"He's very funny.
He uses very good jokes."
It's not like a joke or two.
In my show, I have
like a set of 10 minutes
with the mic, just to set
the comedy set
like Brock, we call it.
Just the comedy set
in the middle of the magic tricks.
So it was literally like
teaching myself a new art form
from the beginning.
So it was difficult for me.
For the crowd, it's like,
"He's very funny."
They don't know
the difference, I think.
Actually, a week ago,
I spoke with someone
that's on my show,
and she told me,
"I love the act,
and you know what?
Your magic tricks,
they were good also.
They're amazing."
I've been doing this for 15 years,
of course, they were good.
[laughter]
But she perceived my show
as a stand-up comedian
using magic tricks.
And I think that the main,
actually, issue with my show is
whether one comes to see the act
when he thinks it's a magic show
or a stand-up comedy show,
because if he thinks
it's a magic show,
it will be damn funny.
And if he thinks
it's just a stand-up comedy,
it will be very surprising.
I love it.
- That's the thing, Yeah.
- I love it.
Now, Itai,
you're not just a magician.
You're also, actually,
an entrepreneur,
and I had the pleasure of
coming to one of your
Sorcerer's Sundays
in Tel Aviv, which was
one of the most incredible
night out experiences I've had.
Tell me a little bit
about this project.
You actually do it with
lot of your magician friends
or you just amaze people
every Sunday at a restaurant.
Yeah.
Actually, it's a weekly show,
the longest weekly show in Israel.
-  Wow!
-  Like we've been running
for six and a half years
prior to the COVID-19, of course.
- Right.
Actually, yeah,
the format is a dinner show.
And the idea was founded
about the principle of
there isn't a dinner show
in Israel,
and there isn't
a good entertainment in English
In Israel.
Like if you have friends
or family from abroad,
people come to Israel.
They can take them to the cinema
or to you know a restaurant,
and it's not entertainment
in English.
- And I think every city
- Right.
in the world, it's the same.
When I was in Argentina,
I went to see a tango dinner show;
or in Spain, flamenco,
or the opposites.
Flamenco, it's in Spain,
I think, yeah.
So every city,
a big city,
tourist city,
there is this dinner show,
show entertainment, whatever,
and it's almost always
in the language of the city,
of the country.
- Sure.
- And Israel is the same.
When you come to Israel,
there isn't anything in English.
So, we this is how we began
thinking about this.
We said, "Okay, we're going
to do a dinner show in English
entertainment for English
speakers with magic,
because magic is cool
and everyone loves magic."
It's for adults, of course.
- Yeah.
- And the cool part is that
every show, every week,
the show differs.
- Right.
- It's like -- it changes.
Yeah, we have like 10,
15 magicians,
all speaking English fluent.
And like for instance, we have
four magicians this day,
and someone comes back
after three months
with his sister that came
from South Africa, or whatever,
they see a new act,
because there are four
new magicians.
So people see the show
over and over again.
We have people coming
like 10 times,
and like 12 times
That's cool.
No and it's not just that the show
on stage is different,
but it's also the interaction
with the people.
I mean, the magicians go
around the tables
and they come up to you,
and you really get
- that whole that whole vibe, which is
- Experience.
Yeah.
The whole experience
it's incredible.
So Itai, I have to ask,
we're doing this over Zoom.
Now, ideally,
we would be face-to-face
in Israel.
But with COVID,
you're still doing shows
and you're still
entertaining people,
and you're still doing conferences.
- Yes.
- How do you do that
during COVID times?
How do you do magic
over a computer screen?
So in the beginning, it was like,
"Okay, we'll just wait
for this to pass,
and we'll go back to our lives."
And then we were like,
"Okay, it takes more time
than we expected."
Yeah. [laughs]
That's I think
all of the world thinks like me,
and it's like,
"Okay, it's a thing."
[laughs]
So, actually,
I thought about you know Zoom.
I said, "Okay,
I'm going to do shows on Zoom,"
it's very different because
I don't have the crowd,
the interaction,
and bringing people on stage,
and hearing the laughs.
And then I said to myself,
"Myself, it's not the same thing.
- So, don't think about it as --"
- Don't force it.
Yeah, you can't wait for the crowd
to applaud and say,
"Okay, you can't just do your show
and expect it to be
the same in Zoom."
No, it's not the same
and it will not be the same.
You need to adapt yourself
and adapt the show for Zoom,
like the last time we did a show,
and I want to do some jokes.
Okay, so I did my bits
and I put everyone on silent
because I need them to hear me,
instead of them hearing people
in the house, and whatever.
Right, right.
So I can't hear the laughs.
I can see them laughing
but it's silent.
It's like a bad comedy club
―it's silence.
You hear only the crickets
from outside.
I'd do a gag,
and that was my mother.
And then I'd hear...
[imitating cricket sound]
Wow.
And I can see them laughing.
So they're having fun
and they enjoyed it,
but it's difficult.
It's different.
That's what it is.
Can you get it --?
Can you get the magic across?
That astonishment?
You know, sometimes people,
when you flip a bottle
and you showed that it's empty now,
people want to go and see it
and they want to put their hand
under it to see that
it's really in the air.
Now, they can't do that, right?
Because now, it's all virtual.
Yes, they can't physically wise,
but I think --
Actually,
Actually it's a philosophical discussion,
because I think the magician --
the people, the skeptic, they say,
"Yeah, you know, I hate magic.
I want to figure out the tricks.
The only thing I want
is to figure out the tricks."
I think this person
isn't problematic.
I think the problem is
with the magician performing.
I think that if the magician --
like magic,
when you think about it,
it's very, very condescending.
I think Seinfeld said
it the best.
Seinfeld said,
"A magic show goes like this.
Here's the coin,
now it's gone.
You're stupid."
[laughs]
This is exactly like what
most magicians do.
They make you feel stupid.
And I think it's a problem.
I think when you're condescending,
and you're being, you know --
How do you say it? Patronizing?
- You know,
- Yeah.
on your audience's expense,
- it's a problem.
- Yeah.
They feel stupid.
When they feel stupid, they want
to figure out the tricks.
I can see --
All the time,  I see my colleagues
going on TV,
and their first phrase is,
"Okay. Today,
I brought something
that will blow your mind.
I'm going to fool you today."
Why?
I think magic isn't a  competition
like me against you.
If you figure out the trick,
you won.
If I fooled you, I win.
- This is not a game.
- Right.
This is not like basketball,
a winner and a loser.
I think we're both
on the same side.
We're having fun.
I'm here to entertain you,
-  and you're here to have fun.
-  I love it.
Let's do it together.
- I love it.
- And I think the crowd feels it.
When they get this feel,
this vibe, they don't want
to figure out the tricks,
like in the beginning of my show,
I'd do a comedy bit
just about this,
about, you know,
the people trying to figure out
the tricks and whatever.
And the subtext is "Don't."
Not because I want to fool you.
I will fool you.
This is not the idea.
This is not my mission.
I love it. No, I mean,
you're so approachable on stage
and your show is
mainly for adults, right?
From what I remember correctly
with some of the jokes,
but really,
I mean I've seen
quite a few magic shows,
because I'm a huge
magic fan myself.
And your show
is one of the most one of the most
that I enjoyed the most
because you're so approachable
and because you just make it
such a unique experience
as a friend,
and it's not as "I'm up here.
You're down in the audience.
Now, just get ready to be fooled,
- then good luck figuring it out."
- Yeah.
Itai, I have to ask.
We're here over Zoom.
Can you show me something
and give me the experience
of what it's like
to be in a magic show
in COVID19 times?
I can try. I can try.
Let's do this.
Can you see the clip?
Yes, I can.
All right.
Let's put it here.
I'm good.
I want you to think of --
- I will --
- [laughs]
- magically place it on the floor.
[laughs]
Nailed it. No? Not yet?
Wait a second.
I have to do this.
You know what?
I'll do this and this.
Opa
- All right.
- Nailed it.
[laughs]
So I want you to think of any
three-digit number
Okay, got it.
No, don't go with 333
because that's very obvious.
Shoot. Okay, now --
Okay. I have a new one
You're good?
Yeah.
You can say it, what is it?
Six-eight-nine.
Four hundred and fifty-nine, yes?
I'll go with six in the beginning,
six-eight-nine.
I have hearing problems.
So let's go with my number, okay?
[laughs] Sound good, sound good.
I'll do it as clear as possible.
You said 689.
I don't know --
wait, wait, what --
That's a note drop,
like a mic drop.
Itai, what the F?
- What the hell was that?
- Magic.
No way.
Okay, I did not --
Now, your viewers will think,
"Yeah, they planned this."
[crosstalk]
"He's playing along."
This is what --
Okay, you know,
this was maybe one of the simplest
but most impressive things
I've ever seen.
[laughs]
I don't think I can continue
to do this interview right now.
I'm a little bit shook.
[laughs]
And I was thinking
of 2-8-9 in the beginning,
and I was like, "You know,
no, I'll change it to 6-8-9."
Yeah, I know, I know.
Okay, that was just crazy.
Okay, let's just move on
and then I'll go.
I'm not going to sleep tonight.
This is just crazy.
Itai, humanity is changing.
Things are becoming
more technological.
People are becoming impatient.
People's standards are rising.
Because of technology,
all the immediate gratification --
What is happening
to the magic industry?
Ans you know because it seems that magic today
is still pretty similar
to what it was
when Houdini was alive.
But now, things are becoming
more technological.
I don't know anything.
So maybe you can correct me.
Where are we headed with this?
I don't know where are we heading,
but things do change.
Humanity change.
Technology change.
Yeah, things change
and magic correlates.
Magic changes also, you know?
It's not Houdini, actually.
One of the first magicians
that made magic as a theatrical,
like prestigious thing.
He wore a suit and everything,
was Robert-Houdin.
It's not Houdini.
Houdini did escapolgy.
Robert Houdin did
big boxes and doves,
and then the grand
illusions with that,
sawing a woman in half,
and then -- whatever.
- Yeah.
- This was in the 50s,
and 60s, and 70s.
In the 80s,
we had Uri Geller,
you know, reading minds.
Things change.
And nowadays, .
people aren't that naive
So they don't want you
to read their minds.
So, the story changed.
Nowadays, it's more like
a psychological mentalism.
Derren Brown in England,
he began all these --
Yeah.
This thing is about --
you know, "I influenced you,
and I read your body language."
Right.
So things change.
You can't say magic is the same
because magic isn't,
nowadays, sawing a woman in half.
Right.
There are magicians
that still do it,
but they can't make a living,
I guess.
They're stuck in the 80s.
Yeah. And so,
how does technology fit into this?
Technology do fit into this.
With technology,
we have new magic tricks.
We have Marco Tempest
doing stuff with iPads,
and we have very visual stuff,
and things do change.
Things change.
Like fifteen years ago,
we had David Blaine
doing magic tricks in the street,
- you know, street magic?
- Yeah.
And he understood
people are more interested
about the reactions.
So David Blaine,
what he did, not only the tricks,
but instead of putting
the camera on the magician,
they pivot
and they showed the reaction.
He did a small trick,
and they had the crowd
yelling for one minute.
So that was Blaine.
And then we have Dynamo,
and whatever.
Nowadays,
we have Instagram magicians.
No presentations,
no nothing,
no patience for the viewer.
People just see a trick,
five seconds, bam, bam, bam,
and it's done.
So I think this is
the way things change.
I don't know whether
it's just the technology,
but it's the medium.
Like nowadays,
with the Zoom.
Yes.
So fast.
- Things change.
- Definitely.
Itai, I can't believe it,
I said that 20 minutes
are going to go away
so quickly, and they have.
- Unbelievable.
- Already?
I have to put you
on the spot once,
and I didn't prepare you for this.
So I'm sorry in advance. But --
- Okay.
- I want you to tell me three words
that you would best
describe yourself as,
or if I ask anybody
watching your show,
when I think of Itai Pinki,
what are three words
that I think of
when I picture Itai?
Wow! Okay.
Actually, three words
that I will describe myself
are very similar
to the three words
one seeing my show
will describe me.
I think I'm bringing
myself to the stage.
- Yeah.
- So when people
see me after the show,
they feel like they know me.
This is good.
This is my idea.
So I would go with --
in this order.
Funny, intelligent, humble.
- Interesting.
- Or modest.
I love it.
[laughter]
Itai, I love it,
I can't wait to see another show.
I can't believe it's been 11 years
since we met
when I was just 13 years old.
- And then that --
- We'll put the pictures.
I'm going to do this,
and the picture
will appear from your bar mitzvah.
Boom. [laughs]
Put it here with your editing.
I love it.
Itai, thank you so much
Thanks, Michael. See you soon.
Bye-bye!
Ciao!